or to Eastern Libya now where thousands
of people have died in floods caused by
a large storm the port city of Duna
appears to be hardest hit two dams in a
valley above the Mediterranean city were
overwhelmed when storm Daniel brought
the heaviest rainfall in a single day in
four decades that's in a huge wave of
water through the city in the early
hours of Monday apartment blocks that
stood well back from the river partially
collapsed into the mud while a bridge
along the seafront was washed away
thousands are still unaccounted for our
Libya correspondent Malik trainer
reports
the worst storm Libya has seen in
decades brought record rainfall and
destruction the impact on Eastern areas
has been devastating but in the city of
derna catastrophic
two of the port City's major dams
collapsed sending walls of water into
the city entire neighborhoods have been
completely washed away
unfortunately with the tail end of the
Danielle storm there has been a sudden
abrupt increase and the water load which
led to the total Destruction of the
major Dam and the sudden flooding of the
city to the extent that about four
square kilometers of the Heart of the
City have been eroded completely
authorities have struggled to reach
dharna it's feared hundreds have been
killed
I hardly believe that the photos are not
able to describe the horrible situation
in dharna it's beyond control it's
beyond the abilities of the government
and the National Society and the people
in the city it's really devastating and
it calls upon the uh assistance from all
the international actors patients and
staff were forced to evacuate several
hospitals across Eastern Libya many
remain trapped in flooded areas
the situation is horrible it's extremely
sad there are people suffering from the
floods and we haven't been able to reach
them Libya has been engulfed by
political divisions for more than a
decade the country has two governments
that slowed down emergency assistance
efforts
the parallel government in eastern Libya
has announced a two-day state of
emergency enforcing a curfew and calling
for people to exercise caution if they
leave their homes the internationally
recognized government in Tripoli
declared Eastern Libya a disaster Zone
it's sent teams of emergency workers
from Western Libya
I've instructed the Ministry of Health
and all relevant agencies to quickly
provide assistance relief convoys will
be dispatched to all cities affected by
this incident we will respond with all
available resources
I'm like trying to joins us now from
Tripoli into Malik we know the numbers
of missing debt are relatively difficult
to confirm at this stage but do we have
any idea of how many people are still
unaccounted for
well according to officials in eastern
Libya it's thousands I saw yesterday we
were seeing of the officials in the in
the Eastern parallel government talking
about 5 000 missing uh the that was from
the Prime Minister uh this morning and
and late last night the minister of
Health from the parallel government is
estimating that number to reach 10 000
uh were seen unconfirmed reports of 3
000 of people
accounted for Dead uh in the city of
Darna other than that number and
thousands still missing but you know
authorities have not been able to reach
the city uh the roads are leading into
dharna are blocked off or destroyed
because of the flooding so until
authorities are able to reach the city
and assess the damage and account for
the an account for the for the dead and
the missing we're not going to know the
number for sure I mean if officials and
authorities are finding it extremely
difficult to get into the worst affected
areas what sort of Aid are people
they're actually being able to access at
this point in time
well in other areas not in the city of
dharna as Aid has begun to reach the
people in need uh I think first and
foremost I mean those that you know
their homes were destroyed an immediate
shelter they also need cash assistance
you know to be able to provide for their
families perhaps get a rent a
accommodation for for their families uh
yeah so I think the most important thing
is shelter uh you know blankets food
water and cash assistance and you
mentioned a little earlier Libya has got
two governments can you just explain how
that is affecting the recovery effort
and how it will in the future as well
it's it complicates everything I mean so
you know we saw yesterday warlord
Khalifa after who asked for the Libyan
Central Bank to give funds to the
parallel government so they can they can
start helping people in need uh you know
we saw the the internationally
recognized government the prime minister
Abdul Hamid to leave I talked about uh
giving funds to the local Council so
they can help the people that are
impacted on a local level so you know
who who supervises the rescue efforts
who gets the money who who where does
the money come from so you know that
complicates uh the the the rescue
efforts for these people and prolongs it
uh so you know hopefully people are
hoping that politicians can put aside
their differences and get help to those
that are in need like I thank you so
much for that that is Malik trying to
for us from AAA